vous venez toucher aux allocations de
chômage ouais comme tous les mois
coiffer la routine quoi
mais ça fait longtemps vous venez vous
ça fait bien six armes en avatar dont
j'avais raison vous rentrez dans votre
septième année de pointage déjà comble
temps passe et ben dis donc ça nous
rajeunit pas tout ça va je me rappelle
les débuts quand je venais pointer là il
y avait un petit nièce quand elle va
c'est que moi petit et je les connais
autres comme ça va dit d attendre
elle va rentrer en sixième bon ben moi
ça va toujours mon train-train jours ici
un jour là j'ai pas trouvé de travail
encore n'ont rien dire
pourtant c'est pas la place qui manque à
quoi vous savez les meilleures places
elles ont déjà été prises
les types n'ont pas attendu les places à
800 mille sept cent mille six cent mille
par mois ils se sont servis roi il
arrive trop tard et vous cherchez bien
mais surtout les matins je vais je
demande bon je me suis ivre espagne face
à vis en me nommant bon mais je sais
déjà pris et à 700 milles à ces prix il
ya 600 milles ces prix gémeaux gym
madame thérèse à 200 millions n'a pas et
bien vous savez à 70 à 80 millions à
plein des places voilà pourquoi pour
qu'elle a plein pourquoi personne n'en
veut j'ai des copains à moi je leur dis
à nouveau la déplacer via une boîte mais
là on veut pas nouvelle fatwa et me dit
on veut pas à la longue vous ennuyer pas
non on s'y fait on s'y fait on s'y fait
vous savez l'après midi au cinéma je
reste deux ou trois séances bien au
chaud et puis quand c'est fini je
descends il arrive doucement doucement
cette heure je descends café je regarde
la télévision jusqu'à la fin en noir et
blanc un des programmes parce que la
couleur là bas ils vont nous la livrée
que le mois prochain
c'est tordu et puis comme ça j'en suis
moi fait allez on sait aujourd'hui mardi
ça vous fait coucher tard tout ça et oui
et oui mais je sens qu'il va arriver
dans mon jeu pourrait plus le faire ça
je le sens je le sens mais dit-il matin
l'or heureusement je peux récupérer le
matin je me lève vers les 10 heures 11
heures
je vais faire un petit tour à la mairie
je le vois aussi repenser son cours a
touché ou bien
retard d'allocations ça n'est pas cette
administration n'est jamais tranquille
nathan paperasserie là quand il ya les
élections je vais voter je regarde les
bulletins je pense la matinée des kanjis
d'ailleurs n'a toujours des nouveaux
challenges le cas cela tient aussi
laissé pointer offs il avait nouveau
site une petite découverte
oui mais les élections c'est tous les
quatre on sait qu'on est mieux que rien
mais vous savez le plus dur c'est pas ça
le plus dur c'est le cas le 14 juillet
le 15 août le 1er mai au noyau qu'est-ce
qu'on s'ennuie les magasins fermés
personnes au travail est un calvaire
les longues journées à ça c'est très
long les jours fériés je peux pas les
voir
mais quand même votre famille vous la
voyez de temps en temps vos frères et
vos soeurs mais non ils travaillent tous
il se lève à 6h du matin ils travaillent
en banlieue un autre des artistes soit
disant part en tournée toujours à droite
à gauche
ma soeur elle travaille dans le métro
elle fait la nuit soit disant qu'ils
disaient ils appellent ça des brigades
faut savoir que si ces brigades là qui
font ça fait que je peux pas les voir on
n'a pas les mêmes horaires
tous nos problèmes et nous en mai mois
surtout moi surtout moi aussi voilà
votre argent de saint albert mais
dites-moi prix
vous savez vous savez pas si on va être
augmentée prochainement
ah non j'ai rien entendu à ce sujet
comment vous avez entendu nature vous
avez pas tous les fonctionnaires ils ont
augmenté et tous les collègues médecine
où normalement on doit suivre alors
c'est chez nous y'a rien d'annoncé un
ben ça c'est capcom a misé à tige un ça
va aller mal 1,6 kg pour nice et on va
faire la grève mais attention nous
compterons fait la grèce et peu de
rigolade n ont fait la grève illimitée
noah attention
comme dans l'eure c'est formidable c'est
un formidable succès c'est formidable
c'est à dire c'est un triomphe chez
triumph et puis on peut dire que vous
avez tapé dans le mille 1 va pas vive
900 noms mais il parle du lac d epuis
ont là j'ai vu un vous avez vos affiches
sur tous les murs de paris comme ça je
remercie mon rang est alors qu'est ce
que vous devez être fiers quand même à
bien sûr que ça fait plaisir parce que
si je vous disais le contraire moi je
serais hypocrite croire c'est ce que
vient alors je me rappelle unités
changement avec les débuts je me
rappelle les débuts d'ee vous avez ou
passion numéro un dans un music-hall ce
travail là bas vous étiez enlevé torchon
je me rappelle même même vous arriviez
au métro vous arrivions vous vous prenez
le métro arrive au théâtre même que ce
n'était pas une première
ouais c'est en deuxième et avait pas
troisième
aulas je me rappelle vous étiez mal
fagoté on portait mal foutu
c'est normal c'était mes débuts c'était
début où il est maintenant et maintenant
si la gloire c'est la loi c'est vrai
vous avez des rhumatismes ou quoi mais
ça c'est résoudre il a donc de le dr y
ait un fort émoi
et puis alors maintenant je pars pas
vous parler des voyages des tournées
partout même à l'étranger et ailleurs et
puis on entend on entend vos chansons à
la radio j'entends vos chances à la
radio eu une faute sur l'auvergnat la
valse à mille des flamands d'étendre la
vie bout on peut dire que vous vous en
avez fait du chemin
monsieur monsieur
monsieur ans éventements déjà quand même
on est vraiment peu de choses
comment comment les gens ils arrivent à
deviner que je suis pieds noirs
ça c'est un mystère que j'arrive pas à
les lucides et j'arrive pas j'arrive pas
je n'arrive pas je sais bien qu'il
existe des clichés des légendes des
lieux combine contre lesquelles on peut
pas lutter c'est vrai on entend souvent
dire que les anglais sont gentleman que
les américains sont des grands enfants
que les écossais sont avares que les
allemands sont disciplinés que 6 ou sont
rusés cetera et cetera et cetera et
cetera et on dit aussi on dit que les
corses n'aime pas le travail
on le dit enfin je sais on le dit ah ben
moi jamais on m'a dit vous vous êtes
corse parce que moi le travail je peux
pas le voir
je ne peux pas le voir les horreurs du
travail j'ai horreur virin gfa six jours
j'aurai déjà un grand jeu voit le moins
cris travail gtr avait à y loger des
boutons gg vraiment j'ai déroulé alors
j'ai des douleurs j'aime pas de travail
je sais pas si tout le monde il est
comme moi
enfin y'a trop de responsables il était
à le dire non non non non je prendrais
pas cet engagement mais moi
personnellement compte ce qui me
concerne j'aime pas le travail moi moi
mon rêve site une place c'est une place
par exemple on va au bureau à 4h30 et on
s'en va à 16h45 le lin ji en se
souhaitant un bon week end
voila voila c'est south oil à wazemmes
consent bras et puis les vacances
pas un mois des vacances un mois de
vacances que je suis à voir ce que c'est
à moi c'est des congés dans des vacances
toute l'année on était la plage en hiver
la montagne de ski ou printemps la
campagne et en automne on se repose on
recharge les accus wallace et voilà moi
c'est je vois voilà c'est ça que jamais
le travail j'aime pas chez patients
moins jeunes pourquoi je vais m'en tire
j'aime et bien que j'aime pas travailler
jamais on m'a dit vous êtes corses
appellent on me voit jeudi deux ou trois
mouches par bart comme si on me dit oh
là là mais vous vous êtes pieds noirs
comment les gens ils arrivent à deviner
ça je comprends pas je comprends pas
c'est un mystère je comprends pas encore
un belge
à vingt kilomètres on arrive à le
repérer un bel monde mon chéri les
belges il doit par l'épouvantable les
belges ils ont un parent né à alger en
rien s'il vous plaît vous voulez vous
une fois ils ont les boules et les
frites en avril s'il vous plaît voulez
vous s'il vous plaît ça c'est belge tout
craché il manque juste le manneken pis
mon chéri le mannequin suisse vue à
bruxelles
enfin je les ai vu la fin du jeu le
cherche parce que c'est pas les
pyramides et simple qui vous unit 4
comme ça de réelle juste auront eux ils
disent que c'est leur tour eiffel et
bons amis ici comme là dessus pour
installer la télévision avec les
antennes la brême ont pas encore la
moitié d'une chaîne
enfin les benchs est facile de
reconnaître mais moi comme les types il
arrive à reconnaître que je suis pieds
noirs ça c'est un mystérieux ipad ou à
je comprends pas ce qu'on attend encore
et oui mais encore jamais on m'a dit
vous vous êtes breton jamais ça je peux
le jurer pourtant garde pourtant il ya
des bretons qui sombra et benjamin on
l'a dit et en plus si tu es tu es si
c'est que ça je suis têtu moi j'ai la
tête moyens et moi un mulet moi j'ai
connu quand génie d'avoir à tête mois
vient avaliser son frère mais n'est pas
la tête moi j'ai la tête qu'on mène dans
le maine
on travaille à paris et je me les crêpes
j'adore les crêpes au grand marnier au
sucre à la confiture les biscuits aussi
les bretons et j'aime les biscuits les
bretons ils aiment le biscuit ah oui les
bretons je vais lui les biscuits je les
lui les bretons avaient gelé l'ubs ont
fait pas sans moi mais j'aime l'écran
chuter dessus j'aime les biscuits kenavo
et toute la smala et jamais on m'a dit
vous vous êtes breton jamais à peine on
me voit et me dit oh vous vous êtes
pieds noirs
mais comment l'équipe arrive encore un
chinois
ça se reconnaît facilement via il ya un
truc qu'on peut reconnaître à chillon à
tous les coups ça se voit comme le nez
au milieu du visage c'est les pieds ils
ont des petits pieds et oui tandis que
moi je fais du 43 fort à cause du
football je jouais libéraux quand on est
descendu en 9e division sa défense et le
mans mais enfin et puis à autre chose il
ya autre chose dans fort concurrents
contre on peut reconnaître un chinois
vraiment à tous les coups c'est qu'ils
sont fort au ping pong
ils sont champions du monde ont marqué
déjà pour manger dans des baguettes
alors de tout petits sont entraînés
grainerie mme balent tac tac tac bon
compte
rennes pas pour un chinois à la rigueur
je l'admets mais comment les types il
faut pour deviner que je suis pieds
noirs ça c'est un mystère mais la
meilleure c'est quand tout à l'heure
pour venir je prends un taxi je prends
un taxi et j'étais en train de discuter
avec le chauffeur là j'étais justement
en train de lui dire que le compteur il
allait très vite et pourtant la voiture
elle aller doucement
et alors oui alors je lui faisais
remarquer sur coup là
alors il me dit mais vous vous n'est ce
pas de là bas jeudi 12 de finlande
parce que je voyais venir lui je voyais
venir l'arnaqueuse voit il me dit non
non non non je voulais dire vous n'êtes
pas de vous n'êtes pas pieds noirs jo je
dis oui mais comment vous m'avez reconnu
ils me diront comment quand vous revoir
quand on vous entend parler alors un il
s'utilise cela et patins qu'on fait
c'est pas vrai ça alors là je deviens
dingue je deviens d'intesa me dire qu'en
votant contre ont attaqué samedi à
canton bon alors admettons
alors dans ces conditions comment ça se
fait à alger aux banques 30 ans que
j'habite et bab el oued
quand je parlais et je parlais jamais un
chip il m'a dit une seule fois au vous
vous êtes billets noirs j'aime ça c'est
l'unique au monde ça c'est unique au
monde
le sujet je me suis j'ai excusez moi de
vous déranger au milieu des
applaudissements je m'excuse mais
excusez moi de vous déranger mais voilà
j'ai j'ai eu une démarche très difficile
à faire je voudrais vous demander une
aide ou un secours ou les deux à la fois
c'est possible ou bien dans une espèce
qui serait le mieux bien sûr les espèces
et riaient mieux que les espèces
alors si vous voulez mais enfin monsieur
vous voyez bien que je suis gêné là vous
êtes l'une est patent que moi mais si
vous savez comme aussi gêné vous savez
vous savez je ne refuse jamais d'aider
les gens quand je peux oui mais je
voudrais bien savoir à quel titre
d'autant plus que je n'ai pas l'honneur
de vous connaître oui mais je suis alors
jugé nécessaire ça je suis gêné alors
expliquez moi je vais vous expliquer
voilà monsieur voilà monsieur monsieur
je suis un artiste sans prétention jeu
et sans fanfaronnade je peux vous dire
que j'utilise un très grand musicien un
très gros budget mais je n'ai pas de
chance je n'ai pas de chance tout ce que
j'entreprends dans la vie dans l'art
dans la musique ne me réussit jamais
j'ai pas de chance je suis guigne
compare un pur à sa reconquête et
scoumoune a comme régiment de malchance
oh là là là là ça fait beaucoup pour un
seul homme
et oui ça fait beaucoup de bouches à
nourrir surtout alors regarde alors
voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai pas de
chance je voudrais que vous me donniez
si vous aussi vous m'aidiez et pourtant
je suis musicien je voudrais que vous
m'aidiez par un petit chèque non
paraissait possible ou alors ou alors
des billets de 10 ou de 50 mais des 56
le mur qui a si vous avez de 50 ya pas
mieux que ça attendez attendez attendez
vous avez de 50
non non c'est trop mesquin l'avait pas
dit ça mais on m'avait dit vous étiez
musiciens oui monsieur ça ça m'intéresse
mais j'ai pas de chance monsieur rien ne
me réussi dans la vie j'ai pas confiance
en me réussit pas mais je vous assure ça
écoutez ne vous découragez pas à laissez
moi faire et comment vous êtes musicien
mais de quels instruments jouets vous
je de quel instrument je joue oui
m'enfin vous jouer peut-être du piano de
la guitare de la batterie
nous non moins je joue pas le jeu moi je
joue j'ai joutes la viole de gambe de la
cua d'art viole de gambe
ap le viol devant vais très bien
attendez moi un instant je reviens sur
si vous avez de 50 c'est mieux ou en
espèces parce que tient compte
voilà monsieur est ce que vous pouvez
pas me jouer un petit morceau en
attendant un petit cercle et de derrière
les fagots
mais dans leur mercie s'agit pas besoin
voyez monsieur là jean cochet vous voyez
la poisse que j'ai monsieur je vous ai
dit que j'étais dit mieux
v remous sociaux je vous ai dit que je
jouais de la viole de gambe et vous a
réussi à trouver le bureau de campagne
et encore presque logique aux choses qui
vous la voilà ma tristesse et demi les
patineurs au musée mais non mais non on
m'avait donné un télégramme pour vous
j'ai oublié dans mes préoccupations
j'avais pas pensé à la junte et les
grands pour vous jeunes et prenez le et
puis c'est tout mais ne partez pas
peut-être que c'est un mandat on sait
jamais le miracle grâce à dieu oulala
c'est encore mieux commandes à deux
mandats
j'ai une très bonne nouvelle à vous
annoncer d'ailleurs je vais vous lire le
texte oui arrive et d'argentine
stop grande vedette internationale stop
susanna raynaldy est prête à chanter
stop elle attend en coulisses stop
alors il faut qu'on puisse y être la
place stop oui mais ça c'était pas dans
le télégramme il me faut partir comme la
wii
jusque pasta fagots et moi même oui
bonjour monsieur j'ai une commission à
vous faire de la part monsieur henri de
quel genre et le petit ou le grand les
moyens assez je vois le bal hakim un
costume et une cravate et il est
toujours une chemise lui non leblanc qui
métisse ou des pantalons avec des pulls
en versant des os et je vois le
matelassier tapissier décorateur non lus
indices qui arriverait papier au sol et
je leur vie
et ouais celui qu'un mari et son frère
et sa soeur avec le film all you know
lui la marque et son frère avec la
filiale m'a aussi arriver ça y est je
vois qui sait celui qui était venu à la
communion de mauricio deux fils à ses
roueries nom à lui n'avait pas pu venir
il a envoyé son frère aîné où le cadet
et moyennes celui qui ne m'est jamais
qui vendait des beignets talent y est
d'ailleurs à quoi celui qui s'est
associé avec chapiteau le marchand des
quatre saisons mais nord il avait pris
la féra son compte avec blood comme
comptable long de leurs représentants
des vins et spiritueux
nos blondes dans l'ancienne interface
t'admire à lèvres les stockages miralles
miralles des ptt ou morales la balance
qui tapait là je crois pas car tu es la
plus qu'à 6 oliveres à la grande
brasserie
il est le beau frère ayew qui faisait
les noces banquiers lequel faye où le
père ou le fils aîné avait une des pires
était toujours chez levi levin les
villes et villes et dit c'est un nom qui
me dit quelque chose
lequel les villes et des qui travaillent
à bord et se sont polis mais boîtier ou
bien les villes hôtes fusible ici au
palais de justice sont les villes les
bus qui passait le tailleur et il verra
alors si apprendre qu évident à l'oues
d'alger connu vidalon un ancien joueur
de football qui faisait hier matin qui
se reposaient l'après midi et qu'il
avait pas l'entraînement le soin d'eux
et taxis vu dans le taxi vous confondez
pas avec charlie brigue est son père il
avait une broderie revenus de laboutarié
à côté de ces rasta le boulanger mais
non vidal qui faisait le taxi qu'il
avait une 404 404 bleue ou noire et
grise avec le toit bleu bleu clair ou
bleu foncé le ciel qui tirait sur le
verbe il garé voulu oui pouvaient ils
avaient des enfants
weeds est un gars une fille une fille
lucy une fille chrome os en effet une
fille on l'appelait la famille dallaire
elle était mariée oui avec qui avec
nationalité de monsieur henri ça lui tu
m'envoies
or il tint huit ans qui faisait
contrôleurs au cinéma rialto fallu dire
d'avancé
bon alors qu'est-ce qui me vu des voix
la wii à savoir si vous avez connu un
homme et dupond dupont
alors que lequel dupont celui qui
faisait un glacier au mare à sainte est
le qui travaillaient cadavres de chiens
0 mais reste celui qui était contre
l'euro se faire à celui qui était
contrôleur au t1 celui qui travaille à
vegas par du jus pas celui qui tape à ce
gouvernement
j'avais du port
touati
comment les choses elle arrive dans la
vie comment il faut le voir pour le
croire
ce jour là dont je vous parle il devait
être exactement 11h30 11h45 à peu près
et il y avait un monde fou au café chez
pépettes au bar palace à bab el oued en
plein la vue de la bouse arias
comme c'est la vérité c'est pas c'est
pas le cas fiez vous avez dû connaître
et chacun c'était l'heure de l'apéritif
chacun paie sa tournée la chaîne la
mienne la tienne la mienne la tienne la
mienne il y en avait que c'est eric la
sienne la sienne la sienne parce que
vous avez des oursins dans la poche et à
cette heure ci qui on voit rentrer à
cette heure-ci qui on va rentré au café
car oui ton lui même car oui tot en
personne il se pointe devant le comptoir
et comme si vous venez d'être nommé
ministre de la culture et des beaux-arts
il demande au patron aphatie lui dit je
voudrais un café bien chaud bien servi
bien sucré et je prépare le cas le
patron bombe au grill été amusé lui cire
son café il se dit il avait l'habitude
des barjots des moitié fou dès 2000 faut
des fois entier il avait c'était parce
qu'ils banque helaba
il a dix pour cent cinquante fois je
vais perdre mon temps avec ce sens
montre là c'est pas la peine bon je veux
lui faire son café puis ça fait rien
nous cherchons café ça fait rien le
lendemain à 8h sur pointes à la même
heure et avec plus de culot que la
veille il demande au patron je voudrais
un café bien chaud bien servi bien sucré
et je paye pas le patron bon bougre
pépettes réussir son café il avait
d'autres choses à faire c'était l'heure
du coup de feu avec le kenya est tout
bon ça va
le surlendemain même chanson mais mr
mêmes paroles ça commençait à devenir un
tube d'ailleurs c'était le matin
exactement et ce mais je suis comme un
ténor à la scala de milan il jappe
répète je voudrais un café bien chaud
bien servi bien sucré il se paye pas et
le manège comme ça ils durent pendant
dix jours dix jours dix jours dix jours
le 11e jour mais pas qu'il en avait
marre il appelle un copain lui qui nous
lopez une armoire à glace faut dire que
vous dire que ceux qui ne l'ont pas la
grâce à dieu c'était vraiment quand on
voulait avoir de l'ombre et qui avait du
soleil on se met à côté c'était un
parasol à lui tout entier c'est un
parasol bon il dit écoute écoute chinaud
fais moi plaisir celui là qui vient tous
les jours
il commence non seulement il m'a port et
la vie mais il commença m'asphyxier et
il m'a pompé l'air alors j'en peux plus
je suis comme ça je vais tomber s'il
vient demain tu vas te le prendre tu vas
t'occuper de lui et tu vas te jeter
comme une bouteille non consignés en
douceur
tu vas me jeter parce que j'en peux plus
de lui je ne peux plus j'ai encore plus
mais tu le fais quand il ment le onzième
jour
toronto il se pointe comme s'ils avaient
une carte orange d'abonnement paris il
se pointe
ils se pointent et demande
je voudrais un café bien chaud bien
sucré bien servi et stein pas si l'on
s'approche de lui didier côtoient vient
vers toi toi vierge
dis moi ça fait dix jours que tu viens
comme ça tu demandes un café bien chaud
bien sucré comme si tu étais toi le
directeur de la plantation de café dis
moi tu y as pas peur toi tu n'as pas
peur
campbellton une regard des budgets moi
j'ai pas peur moi et toi tu as peur tu
toi sinon il se met à claquer de rire et
on pouvait plus diriger moi j'ai pas
peur avant on ne tient pas peur de toi
et quand eto'o se tourner vers le
comptoir est dit alors pour nous deux
deux cafés liens sont bien su très bien
servi et rompait pas
allô oui allô oui ah bonjour monsieur
voilà je téléphone parce que je voudrais
parler à monsieur k 8 au oui non oui
c'est à dire que oui en pcv oui si vous
voulez oui oui pardon oui oui nous
quitter d'accord monsieur ne quittez pas
ne quittez pas allô oui vous êtes là oui
oui moi je voudrais parler
akkaoui tôt oui oui on peut lui il paye
le pcv oui je oui bien sûr oui d'accord
oui
ne quittez pas d'accord mais je suis ne
quittez pas allô oui non c'est moi qui
appelle depuis tous les cp puis ce que
vous faisiez vous avez entendu la
sonnerie c'est mon capitaine oui oui oui
oui vraiment je weeds d'accord monsieur
ne quittez pas d'accord allô allô vous
êtes oui oui à un an je regrette je ne
peux pas parlé plus haut oui pourquoi
voulez vous que je raccroche
pourquoi je vais raccrocher pour
pénélope
mais qu'est-ce qu'on parlait de
l'antiquité et penelope ligue 1 l'as à
la comédie musicale de dany saval et
serge pressée il ya l'équipe lac est là
pour chanter mais je le sais monsieur je
commence aussi ai-je pu mieux quand je
suis sur place alors un open
un produit mature j'ai pas été au match
avec quoi je vais aller au badge avec
les purger sur la tête wallon match mais
je comprends pas bourgue il a dit on va
plus le m dans les grès bakil ibook f3
moi j'ai pas tu m'a même pas demandé le
résultat du match
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont fait
match nul 0 à 0 et à la mi temps
ben quoi robert robert c'est vrai que
c'est mon ami a bien sûr je suis ton ami
tu ne sais pas c'est pareil faut que je
le répète tous les jours
bien sûr et c'est vrai que tu es mon
frère et comment je suis ton frère bien
sûr je suis ton frère justement marqué
sur un papier je suis ton frère ou alors
dans ces conditions est ce que tu es
capable de garder un secret un secret
entre nous c'est la moindre des choses
dans l'écho si tu me dis que c'est un
secret si tu me dis que c'est un secret
tu sais ce que moi je suis un tango tu
sais ce que c'est un tombeau je suis un
tambour alors écoute moi oui oui je vais
t'avouer quelque chose oui j'ai besoin
de 500 francs alors je vais te dire
c'est comme si j'avais rien entendu
allez arrête de faire l'idiot à chaque
fois ci la vérité qui compte sur toi moi
je t'ai jamais embêté mois sur des
questions d'argent - savait pas qui
m'adresser c'est tout batum a fait peur
si c'est une adresse que tu veux ça je
peux te la donner une adresse est ce que
tu as donné la neige j'ai compris j'ai
compris à quoi on a un ami on compte sur
lui comme ça qu'ils n'auraient pas bravo
bravo c'est bien c'est une maîtresse
enfants mais sur bruche blessures
sérieuses mais sorti 500 francs aux les
sorties autour d'un moment où quoi
écoutons supplie ne m'en parle plus et
moi je tends causerait jamais
arrête de pleurer arrête de pleurer chez
soi demandé une fortune à millions j'ai
demandé 500 prend 10 500 francs mais où
je vais sortir ou tu veux moment au cas
où j'ai des frais et des dépenses des
charges des taxes des cotisants et que
tu t'en supplie sera gentil ne manque
aux plus et moi j'y ferai plus allusion
voilà on est comme ça coûte moins robert
j'ai jamais assisté mois pour les
questions d'argent et que si on train de
faire là n'ont jamais insisté mais moi
je te dis une chose
écoute moi bien calmement si tu me les
prêtres et 500 francs tu ne perdra rien
voilà moi je t'annonce moi ma parole
d'honneur
tu me les prêtres dans un mois je te
rend le double de quoi te quoi attends
attends tu m'as dit que tu m'as dit que
si par hasard j'avais 500 francs que ce
n'est pas un hasard
je suis posant un droit tu me rends à la
fin du mois tu me rends mille francs
ouais ça il comprend vite un bien c'est
exactement ça écoute tu sais justement
je sais pas comment je vais faire un
justement j'ai 500 francs sur moi mais
c'est pas à moi je devenais rendent à
kuito je pense que je devais le rendre
d'accord et aux belles et chaudes mais
non c'est la vérité je lui dois
mais je ne sais pas qu'est ce que je
vais te raconter je veux que les traités
mais tu le dis rien tu dis rien comme ça
à la fin du mois tu me rends dans les
mois seulement fret les mois et après on
verra en minant la fin du mois mais
c'est pour toi mais moi j'ai une parole
moi ou mes potes mais attends pas tant à
tanger quelque chose de mieux à trois
projets enrico je leur prouve 6 500
francs comme ça la fin du mois du monde
devra plus que 500
c'est mon côté carlos barria
les amis les amis mes amis mes amis mes
amis à petit lens vous plaît merci merci
si nous sommes réunis tous ensemble pour
guichet là dans la chanson dans ce
bistrot dans ce bistrot sympathique oui
c'est ce pas alors c'est pourquoi c'est
pour rendre hommage à notre ami gaston
du glandier secteur merci beaucoup vous
êtes très gentille ne sait vraiment mais
c'est normal c'est normal à notre ami
gaston du glandier qui après de longues
années de bons et loyaux services nous
quittent pour gagner une retraite bien
méritée une retraite une petite retraite
ne pas fermer bien mérité quand on en a
bien mérité voilà mais si la quantité
qui ne s'est pas la qualité
c'est tout le contraire alors voilà je
vous cause vous devez vous dire si je
n'ai pas peur j'ai pas faire un long
discours je voudrais simplement être
l'avocat de tout le personnel et toute
la direction pour dire combien nous
avons apprécié votre collaboration
fidèle toujours présent à l'ouvragé
toujours sur le rabot toujours sur la
lime toujours sur le fer à souder
toujours partout vous étiez pas été
omniprésent à 1 vous faisiez vraiment
toute l'équipe entière et on voudrais
saluer votre conscience professionnelle
et ne croyez pas qu'on va se quitter
comme ça ça ne croyait pas puisque vous
avez eu la gentillesse de nous offrir
cet apéritif si généreux laissez-moi
vous offrir laissez-moi vous offrir le
verre de l'amitié avec une paille avec
une paille aussi cela tenait prêt chez
vous et voilà et je lève mon verre
également en formant des souhaits les
plus sincères pour votre retraite pour
vous tous ceux qui vous sont chers votre
famille et vos amis et tous ceux qui
sont à côté autour
bon je n'ai pas l'habitude de faire des
discours oui mais tout ce que j'ai à
vous dire c'est que je vous adore à
toutes et à tous si tu le feras ce qui
me rappelle quelque chose ça s'y
attendait dites moi monsieur du glandier
je voudrais vous poser une question en
particulier
je voudrais vous demander quelque chose
mais j'ose pas gêner oser oser voilà
c'est une question qui m'intrigue depuis
longtemps j
je la prends je ne pense pas et je pense
pas la formule est formulée formule et
se dire voilà je voudrais vous demander
et ça m'intrigue
pourquoi vous avez toujours mis au
travail ici tout le temps votre
casquette de côté pour moi c'est très
simple monsieur directory
parce que depuis trente ans que je
travaille dans votre boîte c'est la
seule chose que j'ai pu mettre de côté
que c'est robert tient à l'air d'une
tristesse c'est pas ton habitude tu
savais que ce qui m'arrive
si tu savais que ce qui m'arrive qu'est
ce qui t'arrive ça perdu ton travail
ok perdu je l'avais même pas trouvé
d'abord je cherche même pas à lormes
sais pas je ne veux pas chercher je vois
alors qu'est ce que tu as si tu savais
qu est ce qui m'arrive ixic si tu me dis
pas ce qui est arrivé ne saurai jamais
je crois que ma femme ne me trompe
tu crois ou ai-je en est sûr je crois
que j'en suis sûr et y en a la preuve et
ouais elle a avoué à vous et allez tu
crois toi tout ce que les femmes disent
je ne crois pas quand elle tue motif le
prix d'une robe ou d'un manteau ou d'un
bracelet et ça je le crois pas mais
quand un tissage les croatie officiel
puccini très bon conseil à te donner
l'asile où on ne parle à personne à
personne
je m'entends à personne j'en appellerai
personnes au moins non je les ai juste
dit azarfane à sa fin la malheureuse à
falla le cela qu'il fallait pas parler
un vrai transistors sur evans annoncé
inquiète pas ouais j'ai beaucoup d'
influence sur lui je vais le voir je
vais lui dire de se terrer tout
s'arrangera
mais ces deux selon - ouais enfin jeudi
à kuito aussi quand il maintiendrait
calamars 308 host haut-parleurs qui
marche 24 heures sur 24 mais tu
annoncèrent toute la russe pas possible
ça tu l'as dit à george bush est aussi
moi je les dis tu vas dire prospère le
cafetier dit alors tu l'as dit aussi à
100 vers le cordonnier est réellement
ils étaient fermés
mais mais oui ou sont des trente mille
fans j'avais mes mails où sont les
trente mille francs que j'avais mais au
sort mais comment je vais faire
tu te rends compte je les ai perdus
j'essaie perdu mais c'est pas ça moi cet
argent c'est pas à moi c'est un non pas
tranche de mener la porte à tout à
l'heure quand je vais chercher c'est
perdre il va me tuer mais comme c'est
pas possible je peux pas en gérant vous
fait pas de mauvais sang va perdre
d'argent n'est pas mortelle
trente mille francs de perdu dix de
retrouvés mam jeudi si c'était un mois
encore demi mal de commande minimale
mâles entiers oui justement pourquoi
j'aurais perdu trente mille francs mois
d'un coup comme ça non ça va pas non
s'offrant par son franc je dis pas à la
rigueur c'est comme si c'était des
petites retraites censé être plus
française avait là mais oui soul r b b
oui le tiers provisionnel à cela je n'ai
pas perdu ma famille en raison de dire
les bons sens vont avec les mauvais qui
reste mais je les avais l'air mais je
les avais la wii sont les voilà il est
pressé m
heureusement j'ai retrouvé ici c'est
sympa s'ils les avaient pas retrouvé les
aurait perdus unis
si je vais encore je réfléchissais avait
perdu quand j'aurai fait comment
j'aurais fait mais il aurait fallu que
j'emprunte à un sauveur bavard et
m'aurait pas prêter sauveur il m'aurait
pas prêter il m'aurait pas prêter ce
pourri et après tout le bien que j ai
fait j'ai mangé chez lui pendant un an
et tous à poulies mais ça fait rien
qu'est-ce que je rencontrais avoir
demandé qu'est ce que je regrette
il a pas sauvés sauveur avec mauvaise
affaire mais alors à qui j'aurais
demandé alors j'aurais demandé à un
patient alors elle m'aurait pas prêter
bastien il aurait su que sauveur il a
refusé mon résidents se pourim aurait
refusé à moyens après tout le bien que j
ai fais tu sais pas quand je mangeais
pas chez sauveur je manger chez lui il
est mince affaire mais je leur dirai je
leur dirai je leur dirais vous étiez un
sauveur deux pourraient ensemble qui
s'assemblent pas aller dans le même sac
allez allez c'est pas la peine je sais
où sont mes dents mais maintenant je
sais oui ça c'est bien simple j'en ai
pas alors un droit qui j'aurais demandé
alors à qui j'aurais demandé j'aurais
demandé à un horaire je connais à peine
et ben coups de courage et wasquehal et
d'être qui me les aurait prêté norbert
peut-être qu'il me connaît pas alors que
les aurait prêté tu te rends compte des
norbert qui prenait part est prête et
c'est pourri de sauveur et bastien bref
mais c'est pas vrai mais qu'elle c'est
un article lambert mais c'est une pâte
c'est au miel ce type là il faut le
garder lui faut le garder je leur je
leur dirais vous n'allez pas rentrer un
étrange il me prêtez vous me prêtez pas
vous êtes mes frères vous soit disant
l'amitié les frères allaient les aléas
ne regrette pas oh là là mais quel brave
type ce norbert sympathy faut le garder
lui a heureusement qu' à norbert on a
mis si ça se trouve même pas il aurait
voulu que du rand
comme je le connais il m'aurait dit non
non c'est pas la peine c'est pas la
peine pour pas de moi mais tu as norbert
voilà c'est ton argent juste l'erreur
c'est normal en fait mais non à 30 mille
francs c'est pas la peine rose regarde
les abeilles alors parce qu'ils se
seraient vexés on aurait fait des îlots
et en justice des procédés aura bon ça
va ça va jaur écrasé le coup ça va mais
quel brave type the north bay 1 et tu te
rends compte qu elle brave type jeunes
ils me prêtent 30 mille francs
il veut pas que je lui rende et bien
puisque c'est comme ça tout de suite je
vais aller lui demander ses trente mille
francs à norbert et on en parlera plus
voilà
si si si je serai directeur du mama
qu'est ce que je ferais pas ah bah non
je te serai un million par mois
même deux millions même 3 millions même
4 millions même 10 millions que je m'en
fous c'est pas moi qui paye alors qu'est
ce que je ferais pas les bras
d'abord je viendrai au travail alors que
je voudrais qui c'est qui va me dire
quelque chose
le premier qui me fait une réflexion je
me jette comme un vulgaire vaut rien
allez donc passer à la caisse avec un
salaire que cela allait mais monsieur le
directeur si je me suis permis qu est ce
que je me suis permis à les airs
pascal aka ce qu'est ce que je vais
perdre mon temps avec des vulgaires
lardin déballer à l'aller alors qu'est
ce que j'aurais pas confie qu'est ce que
j'aurais pas comme fi des poupées de
filles auraient des poupées des camions
j'aurais dit des camions des blocs mais
moi je leur dirai où vient je leur dirai
non véronique laisse pas tomber les sma
tomber veronica tous les soirs la brenne
champagne cognac whisky demi panaché sa
grande des cinq ans puisque mais je me
souvenais plus de dire que de limonade
alors ça énorme la distance soient
tombés tous les soirs dans les cabarets
la tienne la mienne dans les boîtes
rétro disco strip états et aux qu'est ce
que c'est et d'agrumes arabique derrière
moi ou quoi
c'est ma tombés d'accord je suis beau
garçon mais y en a d'autres peut-être
aller voir les malheureux voix grâce à
dieu ça va aller allô allô c'est qu'il a
l'honneur d'être au bout du fil de
l'appareil qui est devise nouvelle
mesure cela de moi si tu me vois pas de
suicide
laisse tomber dsk mais oui je cible oui
tu m'a acheté une bague avec un
solitaire avec deux solitaires
alors c'est un double solitaire tu vas
acheter une voiture qu'elle m'a une
mercedes j'ai pas confiance dans les
voitures espagnoles voilà c'est tout
oui j'ai bon oui bon mais je sais bien
mais je si oui peut être non pas demain
mais non pas demain demain je suis pris
j'ai un conseil d'association avec
l'école l'un des jeux je sais je
pourrais oui je bois offre son koh lanta
gonzesses l'art j'aurai un appartement
j'aurai un appartement 15 pièces cuisine
presse salle de bar des débarras avec
dessins créés tout par la télévision
partout la télévision partout la
télévision partout partout même dans les
matins comme ça pas mal et je vous la
laisse passer un moment
qu'est-ce que je mangerai pas dans les
restaurants qu'est-ce que je mangerai
pas dans mes restaurants rennais volent
au vent des bouleaux vendée volent au
vent développement des volumes en
développement d'éboulement et puis des
choses compliquées un juste après des
pommes de terre en robe de chambre
ça doit être bon et ma mère jamais lancé
ma mère dit mme américain fait des
pommes de terre bouillies on comprend
que c'est nous qu'on enlève les
épluchures
après après après je tarde café
pousse-café pousse le pouce carré aussi
là qu'il a voulu pousser le café pousse
le dernier puisque assainissement tels
que posco et le pousse café après une
cigarette qu'il bouffe et une autre vers
est mauvaise des terres mais depuis
vendredi repart par arbre qu'est-ce
qu'il est intelligent celui-là même
quand ils voient pas généralement je les
mets dans la poche de caisse que
signerait pas comme cheikh
qu'est-ce que signerait pas compte
chèques réussir et des chercheurs et des
chèques sur et les venir payer quand je
me présente le maximum
alors qu'est-ce que je dirais pas comme
m invisible très d'el hadj du retrait
des lettres qui tend d'abord
j'appellerais la secrétaire par l'eau
par leur mémoire elle isabelle de
glatigny venez-y prendre le courrier
c'est là qu'ils attendent faisait
patienter six sont pas contents qu'ils
aillent chez leur mère alors prenez je
dicte cher monsieur votre affaire que
vous m'avez parlé l'autre fois en deux
sur dieu elle m'intéresse pas en ce
moment d'actuels d'aujourd'hui coin des
points de 106 ans la caméra
vu que j'en ai une vue que j'en ai vu qu
elle me paraît plus costaud donc on
stars attention accord du participe avec
sous-optimale et - véreuses que la vôtre
alors veuillez que ses dires elle
s'était pas et cetera et cetera et
cetera et cetera
comme ça le type crois pas que c'est une
tranche 1 est ce que je serai pas
convoyage jeta prix des voyages à tout
va des voyages à tout va ce prix des
voyages à touba le premier pays où je
voudrais aller c'est en espagne pour
visiter les châteaux
il paraît qu'ils sont incroyables les
cercles au canada